are there any other mind-blowing kitchen
hacks you think everyone should know
up your butt sean
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by jennifer garner
she's a golden globe award-winning
actress with more than 60 tv show and
film projects over the course of her
more than two decade long career
her latest movie though is the family
feel good yes day which is currently
streaming on netflix
check it out but first the wings of
death jennifer garner welcome to the
show
thank you so much i am i guess i'm
really excited to talk to you and and
very happy to be here how are you around
the spicy stuff because one time i did
see you
eat it looked like a serrano pepper out
of your garden and you immediately
chased it with a garden hose how are you
feeling possibly reliving that trauma
here today
i don't add sriracha to my mac and
cheese i'll just say that i
i am just so happy with vanilla and
chocolate
but okay but that's all right i'm i'm a
i'm an adventurous person
classic hot sauce it says
[Music]
i'm fine it's not a problem
[Music]
so your new movie yesterday mirrors the
real-life garner family tradition
inspired by the 2009 children's book
whereby for one day only
you'll acquiesce to your kids demands
whether it's eating ice cream for
breakfast or camping out in the backyard
how did that annual holiday tradition
originate do you have any advice for the
parents who may be inspired to do the
same after seeing this film
it originated because of the 2009
book i also had a 2009 edition her name
is serafina
it was her favorite and because she
really dreamed of having her own
yesterday
to the point that i finally had to give
it to her follow amy kraus rosenthal's
children book yesterday
that's the instruction manual and then
can you talk us through how to make a
froot loop pizza
and was that a dish that you were able
to perfect on your first try or did it
take some experimentation
froot loop pizza you ready
pizza dough marshmallow fluff
into the oven very hot oven very hot
until the pizza dough is cooked
and the fluff is browned it comes out
sprinkle liberally with
fruit loops and then
[Music]
enjoy
no problem so as a leading lady turned
startup co-founder with once upon a farm
i'm curious your perspective on a
question that we once asked your dude
where's my car co-star ashton kutcher
where are pitch meetings more likely to
be parodies of themselves
hollywood or silicon valley really great
question
definitely i've been in pitch meetings
where everyone is talking lingo and you
just feel like do you guys
get how do you do you get that you're a
parody of yourselves
but you know we're all in it together
and so i have a laugh but when i go to
grocery store meetings
and i make sales calls to different
grocery stores
they talk in another language too don't
think that they don't they're like you
know
this could do really well in the wet
wall and i'm like what's a wet wall it's
where they are
you know sprinkling spraying down
produce and it's there's a whole other
world in of cpg what's the most
mind-blowing thing you've learned
making food at commercial scale you know
from the processes to the relationships
it's such a fascinating industry from
the outside looking in
i love the supply chain of it i love
actually
um going you know my farm is part of the
supply chain my family farm in oklahoma
and i love watching how we choose what
to plant because we don't have
refrigeration on our farm
we have to choose to plant sweet
potatoes pumpkin squash something that
can be transported
at its peak ripeness so that it can
immediately
be cold pressure processed put into a
pouch and sent straight to
grocery stores right away and that's
that's just really cool and thinking
about all the different ways that fruit
and vegetables
excuse me come to us and trying to do it
in a way that impacts the environment
the least
but also gives you the most robust
organic
biodynamic you know farm fresh goodies
for your babies
not to fish for free consulting but we
have been playing around with this idea
of a hot sauce
for kids as an expert in the category
and a parent yourself
do you have any words of warning or
wisdom before we dive into that
i wouldn't spend a ton of money on it
sean
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think i am doing really well that's
the first one i really
mm-hmm catching a little burn it's just
a little
it's easy though
mm-hmm
so for a lot of jennifer garner fans the
entry point was the charismatic disguise
wearing taekwondo practicing cia agents
sydney bristow and alias
the show was j.j abrams directorial
debut and
cenophiles to this day can see the alias
blueprint in jj's later work
at what point did you recognize or buy
into him
as an action sequence directorial
maestro
oh my gosh i'm so happy to know that
people can see alias in his later work i
didn't i've never heard that before that
i'm gonna take
even more of a personal ownership of
everything jj then
um jj knew exactly what he wanted to do
he was a
super clear director from day one i
think he writes as if he's going to
direct and has always written with the
visual
in mind and also the music in mind he's
such a musician that it's really easy
to see the music and how he wants
something spoken or done
and the first time i was on a harness
and climbing a wall
um he and i were both kind of like oh my
gosh this is this doesn't happen in
felicity and this has never happened to
me before
but we were both so up for it and so
eager and excited for the challenge
and he always had the camera moving no
matter what it was
always like zooming next to me zooming
past he just was never afraid of just
going for the shot
hellfire's devil okay that doesn't sound
very methodist
[Music]
no problem there we go
so i know that farming has been a theme
throughout your life from your mom's
farm in locust grove
oklahoma to the orchard that you have in
california
to even co-founding a farm to high chair
baby food company
as a seasoned beekeeper do you have a
favorite fun fact or story about the
fascinating and complicated life inside
the hive
you only need to know a little kid's
version
of what happens inside a hive to be able
to put on a whole
get up and open a hive and see it come
to life
my kids when they were babies could say
drone
worker let's spot the queen guard bees
it's like
they are the most fascinating coolest
creatures
on the planet one of the byproducts of
this pandemic is an explosion
in an apartment agriculture do you have
any
pro tips for uh people who are just now
starting to embrace the green thumb
lifestyle
i would say the most important thing is
just to
do it experiment with how much water you
give them experiment from
with what you put in the soil and it's
just there's nothing better
especially if you have little kids
little kids are more apt to eat
something they've grown and they can
pick fresh off the vine themselves
than anything else that's the best way
to teach veggies
doing some taekwondo yeah knocking out
these wings
uh-huh i'm a hot winged ninja
i see it
fine
[Music]
that's fine okay jennifer we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham we're doing deep
dive on our guests instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context and one pervasive theme
throughout your feed
is nature inspo particularly these
remote cabins
does that stem from a longing or
catharsis and escaping the eye of
hollywood or is that just uh reading way
too much into that
i have a little bit of a an apocalyptic
fear
um and really i think i would like to
know that i could live
off the grid on an island somewhere that
was always in a beautiful fall colors
so yeah do you have a lasting memory
from sitting courtside with steve
ballmer
he really does seem to let it loose
during the clippers games he was
amazing the bombers are incredibly
um focused on early education in the
united states
as am i and so i was there on behalf of
save the children and as a friend of
theirs letting me bounce ideas off or
donating to different projects that we
might be starting up or interested in
so we would sit and talk really
intensely or at least connie and i would
about
kids and poverty in america and rural
poverty and birth to five in the brain
science and then steve would get up and
just like
um so yes it was a memorable that was
really fun
[Music]
i have no problems sean this is nothing
[Music]
i'm trying to get a read trying to get a
read jennifer it just seems like
you can poke her face yeah no i am i am
poker facing
so 13 going on 30 is one of the most
enduring cult classics of the early
2000s even
recently being referenced in ariana
grande's thank you next
music video have you given any thought
to why that film in particular its
special ingredient that's allowed it to
have this everlasting place in the pop
culture zeitgeist
um i think there's no bigger wish
fulfillment for a 13 year old
than to be 30 and conversely i don't
know
any you know 30 year old who wouldn't
like to dip back into her 13 year old
body and see what that was like
so i don't know there's just that kind
of there's a it's just so whimsical and
it was actually such a perfectly
constructed movie by the late great
beautiful
soul gary winick playing generique had
so
and continues to have so much meaning
for me
and it did at the time as as well and
i don't know that i like really carried
the theme with me
as much as i carried the feeling of
playfulness you know that i had in my
body while we made that movie and
just the ambulance of that character and
of that time
are all kind of connected in this warm
hazy fuzzy rosy glow
[Music]
oh honey badger doesn't give a [ __ ] i
mean that's what it says
and it's true of the sauce yeah
i feel that i'm aware of honey badger
[Music]
i feel that okay jennifer it's not every
day that we're graced with the presence
of an ambassador from west virginia and
that's a distinction that was actually
made official
when in 2007 you were named west
virginian of the year by the charleston
daily mail
every year your hometown of charleston
hosts the vandalia gathering
celebrating the uniqueness of west
virginia's mountain culture
how would you distill the mountaineer
lifestyle to
a complete outsider um
gosh um
[Music]
i feel like you really held back until
number seven and then there's a lot
of that honey bad
it's a steep ramp up yep it's a steep
ramp up um
you really had me feeling kind of cocky
didn't ya um
okay well i will tell you about the
vandalia festival that
my memory of it i mean i would go to a
vandalia well vandalia
festival right now and take you with me
because i know you'd love it
um it's just like bluegrass bands
playing under every tree tall tale
contest where people tell you the most
charming charismatic version of a tall
tale you ever heard
but anyway the mountaineer um attitude
is mountaineers are always free don't
step on me leave me alone
um just leave us in our mountains i'm a
little more like hey y'all you know
come on in have some honey badger
on the topic of those tall tales how
much did the folklore
affect you or touch you as like a child
like did you ever have uh
nightmares about the pleasant point
mothman or anything like that i love the
pleasant point mothman um
i don't know i definitely believe
there's no good story that can't be
improved upon
um my dad worked for union carbide and
they had
a camp for all the kids and it was
called carbide camp
and um there was somebody there who told
ghost stories and
we were deep in the mountains somewhere
just being filled with carbide
propaganda
and singing songs about this chemical
plant
um and yeah i was terrified of the
monsters that they told us about that
hid in the woods
which is the union's superior regional
delicacy the fried bologna sandwich or
the pepperoni roll
pepperoni roll hands down gino's thank
you
i'm a little nervous now after that
honey badger
whoa going in the only way out is
through sean
i'm just following you through the door
hot that's fine yeah that's fine
take a lap take a lap that's warm hot
that's very hot okay
so here at first we feast we're acutely
aware of the way that the celebrity
world has flooded the food world in
recent years with varying degrees of
credibility but your bonafides
they're just as credible as they are
humble as proven by your pretend cooking
show
i've seen you try the cook's illustrated
method of softening
butter with a warm glass are there any
other mind-blowing kitchen hacks you
think everyone should know
up your butt sean
i get it i get it
flashbacks
yeah um
colleen colleen um
okay let's think about kitchen hacks
the only other one i can think of is
also to do with softening butter because
it is so
important and vital that you start with
root
temperature ingredients if you're going
to bake so if you have
eggs that are cold from the fridge put
them in a bowl of lukewarm water
and if you need softened butter right
away you don't want to wait for the
you don't want to wait at all then you
you can
you can um put it through a cheese
grater
how big a deal was it for you to get a
inagarten cosine
she actually says she is adorable and
smart and not at all performing that's
just who she is
i think she's really special she would
never do this to me sean
i know when she would be appalled at
this behavior
actually she wouldn't she would find it
funny
i mean the fact that
i know garten whom i revere
and who taught all of us to cook the
whole world
when i'm doing the pretend cooking show
it's an homage obviously to
aina it's just more than i can handle
you've said that you're a geek for food
tv what's uh what's your
what's your all-time cooking show's
mount rushmore
barefoot contessa in the kitchen with
martha
i mean i can do giada bobby flay can be
fun
i mean i can do them all i i mean
obviously it's like julia
julia freaking child but
i feel great
not fun but i think after the last one
almost like a vacation yep oh no the
kick happens later oh no
no no
so i know that you didn't always have
hollywood aspirations in fact
when you were a young girl you were more
drawn to regional theater
and dance studying ballet for 10 years
at the peak of your dance training
what's your personal record for
consecutive pirouettes
i've never been a good pure wetter and
that's why i'm sitting here in this
chair
instead of just happily teaching ballet
somewhere in a little studio in west
virginia
what advice would you give out for
picking out the perfect pair of point
shoes
i don't i think don't just take whatever
points you you have
at face value don't be afraid to cut out
the shank
at three quarters and to break the box
and um yeah that's what i would say
technical vernacular pro tip from
jennifer garner and then finally as
theaters prepare to
open can you provide us with a a
quintessential
classic production that you'd recommend
to someone who's never been to a ballet
before in their lives
oh my gosh so many maybe c rapmanski's
firebird
maybe see don quixote because it's just
so
vibrant and nc isabella boylston
as ketri
[Music]
i'm shaking but other than that cheers
[Music]
cheers
oh misery
but going back in going back in
jennifer garner committed to the process
okay okay jennifer garner here we are at
the closing credits of our spice packed
meal but before you go
i want to touch on one last thing and
that's a commencement speech that you
gave at your alma mater
denison university in your parting words
to the graduating class of 2019 you told
students that they're lucky if their
life is quote unquote
65 percent happy while your brain drowns
in hot sauce i have to ask
why is it important to try to live at 65
happiness and where did you come up with
that specific number
[Music]
well
um um
well i i mean i just think that
it's easy to just kind of always be
looking ahead and
saying when i get x i'm going to be
happy when i get why especially right
after you graduate from college
you know you don't have like that goal
that's easily achievable and you think
well when i finally get my own apartment
when i finally get engaged
whatever it is but it's like just be
happy now and i think this last year has
been
a really um a really good
that last one was very
[Laughter]
the last year has been um you know has
taken care of a lot of that for a lot of
people anyway
wise words from jennifer gardner through
the pain of it all but
still standing after her bout with the
wings of
death and now jennifer garner there's
nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera
that camera probably just the camera
you're looking at though
let the people know what you have going
on in your life um i have a movie
opening
it's uh starting march 12th
on netflix it's called yesterday and um
it is about saying yes and um
that's mostly something that i would
recommend unless this guy calls you
it's just a joy-filled colorful day of
yes
after a year of no
that's all
great job jennifer great job america
thank you you asked really great
questions
really great interview thank you thank
you jennifer i appreciate that and uh i
i hope
in the end it was all it was all worth
it to go through it you know just wish i
could hug your neck
with my hands
buzz have you heard the news hot ones
nugget honey it's honey infused with
pepper x
the best of two worlds everybody honey
now
nugget nugget honey honey honey
honey nugget nugget honey honey
hot ones nugget honey get yours today
and see what all the buzz is about
only at heatness.com
to be no to be
or not to be now on heatness.com
it's how
oh i'm a bee